the general hospitals are wreck the
university's been blown to bits and
there's no point turning up for work
unless it's on wheels after three years
of occupation everyone in mosul has lost
someone or something
like twelve-year-old Miriam who was shot
in the head by an is sniper now she can
barely see and her face is badly
disfigured where's my manager with named
Jack we first met Miriam at an
overcrowded clinic in July but the
doctor said she wasn't eligible for
treatment because she still had some
vision in one eye later local donors
paid for an operation to remove shrapnel
in her skull but Miriam still needs
three more procedures so the 12 year old
spends lots of time here playing with
their cousins at her uncle's house she
doesn't go to school
because the kids say she's unpleasant to
look at first my 40 I love my rock my
authority mother that's a bit Miriam was
shot in June on a day referred to here
as the Pepsi factory massacre
is snipers targeted thousands of
residents as they tried to flee the
city's oldest neighborhoods hundreds
were slaughtered on the road which
skirts the soft drinks plant Merriam's
father thought they killed his daughter
too funny
the male flower why go for Annie Bechard
but Omaha Surratt and no less official
Miriam Miriam maintained and Allison she
locally here know her as she ship now
honey we have de la yaani
mr. ahmed can't pay for her treatment
because he doesn't have a job as taxi
was blown up by a bomb or a missile
strike he's not sure which Nicole Laura
have worked at area we tracked down the
surgeon who treated Miriam earlier this
year at a hospital in Kurdish Iraq her
condition is stable he says but she'll
need her nose and eye socket rebuilt if
you can't correct this big defects now
she can draw normally even on
psychological aspect and on physical
aspect she can develop a normal
development dr. Challa is willing but he
doesn't have much time with 2 million
refugees in this part of Iraq patient's
needs are rarely met
like the city she lives in Miriam needs
help but she's got a future she has a
dream she wants to live an ordinary life
to be a teacher and educate her pupils
in a tranquil land John sparks Sky News
in northern Iraq